توجهنا إلى نيو هامبشاير لمقابلة هذه المرأة الرائعة التي تعافت للتو من فيروس كورونا ، هل تشعر بأنني محظوظ اليوم ، أشعر وكأنني لم يكن لدي أي موقف لا يصدق بالنظر إلى أن كل ما حدث في حياة جيري تشابيل البالغة من العمر 102 عامًا هي ابنتها جوليا تشابيل عندما كانت والدتها طفلة منذ ما يزيد قليلاً عن 101 عام ، كان لديها ما نطلق عليه الإنفلونزا الإسبانية التي كانت وباءً هائلاً خلال الحرب العالمية الأولى ، وتقول عائلة جيري تشابيل إنها نجت من جائحة الإنفلونزا في أوائل القرن العشرين و فيروس كورونا في أوائل القرن الحادي والعشرين في عام 1918 كان كل من جيري الصغيرة ووالدتها في حالة مرضية خطيرة وأخبر الطبيب والدها أنهما سيموتان جهز نفسك ولكن هذا رأيي الطبي لكن ابنتي وأمها نجوا من الذهاب إلى الكلية وحصلت على حصل كل من البكالوريوس والماجستير على مدرسين وتزوجا بعد الحرب العالمية الثانية مباشرة ، حيث توفي زوجها منذ أربعة عقود تقريبًا ولكن كان لديهما طفلان وهناك  نحن الآن ثلاثة
أحفاد وستة
من أحفاد الأحفاد بعد تقاعد جيري
كانت مصابة بسرطان الثدي وسرطان القولون
وقد تغلبت على كليهما ، هل يمكنني مناداتك يا جيري ،
إنه لمن دواعي سروري مقابلتك ، شكرًا لك
كيف تشعر أنك امرأة رائعة
لماذا سأفعل  أخبرك لماذا أنت
متواضع ولكنك مصاب بفيروس كورونا
وقبل مائة عام واحد
أصبت بالإنفلونزا الإسبانية ونجوت منها مرتين ،
أنت امرأة رائعة جيري
مقيم في مجتمع كبار السن
في ناشوا لعدة سنوات حتى الآن يا أمي
في هذا اليوم ، جاءت ابنتها
لزيارة الابتعاد الاجتماعي ولا تزال الأقنعة
مطلوبة ، نعم ، علينا الاحتفاظ بالقناع ،
نعم ، هل تعرفين الجزء العلوي الذي يجب
أن أسرقه منك ،
فلا أعتقد أنك ستعيده
إلى موظفي  شعر مجتمعها الكبير
بالضيق والحزن عندما أثبت جيري
إصابته بالفيروس التاجي ، لكن
عندما أخبروها بالتشخيص ، كان لديها
موقف لا يُصدق وهي التي تعلم أنها
كانت تأخذها كل يوم وقالت أعتقد أنني مريضة
هناك أخبرتني أنني مريض لكنني  م  لست مريضًا
ولكن مثل الأنفلونزا الإسبانية
ونوبتي السرطان جيري تشابيل البالغ من العمر 102 عامًا ،
وتمكن من درء فيروس كورونا
أيضًا ، شكرًا لك على السماح لنا
بمقابلتك ، شكرًا لك غاري توكمان سي إن إن
ناشوا نيو هامبشاير